willkommen bei philo cars jetzt geht es
ums leben
das thema des lebens wir ja jörg was ist
leben wir haben verschiedene irgendwie
verschiedene vorstellungen davon aber
irgendwie ist klar dass für eine
vorstellung haben
das erscheint mir klar zu sein jeder
gesagt ja erleben dass das weiß ich aber
wenn man es versucht zu definieren stößt
man vielleicht auf probleme könnte ja
sein und hast du da vielleicht eine
präzise definition ja also du hast
völlig richtig gesagt das problem am
lebens begriff ist dasjenige das wir
immer schon leben wir haben alle
eigentlich eine reflexive vertrautheit
mit dem leben
wir brauchen eigentlich gar kein begriff
des lebens zu haben weil wir immer schon
leben
wir haben es in unserer natur das leben
natürlich kann man sich jetzt fragen wir
uns definieren muss und da gibt es
verschiedene theorien also eine
definition des lebens begriffs besagt
leben ist eine science weise von natur
gegen stellen könnte man sagen die sich
durch drei merkmale auszeichnet dieses 1
weise das ist zum einen organisation zum
anderen regulation und schließlich
evolution
ich habe mal kurz beschreiben was es in
diesen momenten auf sich hat also
organisation könnte man sagen dass die
gliederung eines gegenstandes in mehrere
teile und prozesse die wechselseitige
bezogenheit regulation ist die
ausrichtung in einem gegenstand
ablaufenden prozesse in haltet also die
versorgung des systems mit stoffen aus
der umwelt das ist die regulation
ernährung aber auch abwehr von
schädlichen einwirkungen von außen und
evolution schließlich ist diese
transformation der der lebewesen wie zb
durch fortpflanzung
das ist also die revolution auch
varianten die dadurch möglich sind
dessen so diese drei kern momente des
lebens definierende momente des lebens
und da es gibt natürlich auch noch
andere theorien aber das ist die
klassische heutzutage gültige definition
des lebens also interessant ist auch
dass sich das zeigt dass sein irgendwie
auch stark mit leben verknüpft genau
also es gibt natürlich zwei verschiedene
existenz weisen also die tasse existiert
auf eine bestimmte weise aber sie wäre
jetzt nicht lebendig also existenz leben
ist eine besondere form von existenz
könnte man sagen genau verknüpft mit
lebewesen genau also nie bewiesen aber
auch sobald lebewesen ist könnte es halt
lebt es richtig ist tasse ist das
wirklich pflanzen hingegen schon
pflanzen sind bis sie geht könnte man
sagen nach der klassischen theorie und
das bringt mich jetzt eigentlich auf die
erste klassische theorie in der
philosophie des lebens das wäre
aristoteles aristoteles vertritt in
seiner theorie einen so genannten höhle
im office muss höhle im office muss
dessen zwei begriffe höhle ist der stoff
und nordsee ist die form und für ihn ist
alles lebendige zusammengesetzt aus
stoff und aus form aber die form ist
etwas ganz spezifisches ist nicht die
form der taste die tas nach form die das
lebendige ausmacht sondern die seele die
psyche die seele verleiht dem stoff eine
ganz besondere form so dass der stoff
nun glaubt sich organisch strukturiert
ist und lebensfähig ist
man nennt das dann auch intel hier also
dass lebewesen hatten sich ein ziel ein
tellers auch das team strebt das sind so
alles charakteristika des lebens die
seele unterscheidet aristoteles dann
noch weiter in verschiedenen stufen
erkennt also verschiedene szene kennt
einen eher seele zum beispiel
er kennt aber auch noch eine höher
stufige seele die dann eher rational
strukturiert ist und je komplexer die
seele strukturiert ist desto mehr
involviert sie auch die niederen stufen
also wir menschen haben natürlich auch
einen eher seele wir müssen natürlich
auch tierisch existieren wir brauchen
stoffwechsel aber wir haben eben auch
noch eine sehr vernünftige sehen uns die
höhe dieser jungs stufen geschichte sind
desto mehr fassen sie auch etwas
aggressiv seele stufen in sich unter
sich das ist eine theorie
das könnte man sagen dass eine
ökologische theorie des lebens heraus
todes
wenn du jetzt sagst legen könnte man mit
theologie verknüpfen also mit einem
gewissen ziel
wie sieht es da mal pflanzen aus silber
pflanzen an pflanzen wäre es so
stoffwechsel ganz das ist das ziel das
leben natürlich auch fortpflanzung
pflanzen da wenn sie sich ja auch
vorteile wieder schön heißt irgendwie
das als eicheln dann herunterfallen auf
den boden und neue keimlinge bilden ja
auch da ist die fortpflanzung
zentraler punkt der unterschied ist eben
der dass dieses ganz natürliche
lebensräume jetzt mal keine vernunft hat
kein rational sehen teile und ich treffe
es ihnen wirklich aus hat ein ziel aber
kein reflektiertes ziel ist kann sich
keine ziele setzen er hat ihn sich auch
bei tieren instinkt artig einziehen
aber es kann jetzt nicht zwischen
verschiedenen zielen wählen oder
lebensentwürfen gehen
das leben wird sich da nicht selbst zum
gegenstand das leben reflektiert wird
nicht auf sich selbst wir reflektieren
auf unser leben wir formen unser
natürliches leben weiter und uns fällt
es extrem schwer unser ziel im leben zu
sehen
häufig auch genau unser leben kann auch
manchmal selbst zum problem werden ein
guter punkt kann eine katze kann das
leben einer katze selbst problematisch
werden kann die katze sagen was höre ich
denn dafür ein katzenleben ein
katzenjammer
kann sie wohl nicht unser leben kann als
krise geraten ja genau
also aristoteles ist so der zentrale
ausgangspunkt
wir haben dann auch noch weitere
theorien zum beispiel bei kant jemanden
kann man kann eine der bedeutendsten
philosophen der aufklärung der
perspektive wird nun aber das leben
nicht mehr so sehr und theologisch hier
ist aristoteles getan hatte stoffen form
psyche als prinzip als unter logisches
prinzip sondern es theologisch als
erkenntnis theoretisch er fragt nicht so
sehr wie es das leben in der welt
geschaffen sondern fragt wie reden wir
über das leben oder wie reflektieren wie
auch das leben also die urteilskraft die
reflektierende urteilskraft an vermögen
spielt eine ganz wichtige rolle und kant
hat eben auch eine kritik der
urteilskraft geschrieben
eine kritik der ästhetischen urteils
kräften eine kritik der theologischen
urteilskraft und diese zweiten kritik
fragte eben nach der verfasstheit
unseres urteils über lebendiges ok und
genau also kann auch ein zitat noch
vorlesen
es geht eben um das den den organismus
auch das ist eine ganz zentrale
begrifflichkeit und sagte zum beispiel
alles in der welt ist irgendwo zu gut
nichts ist umsonst
man ist durch das beispiel dass die
naturen ihren organischen produkten gibt
berechtigt ja berufen von ihr und ihren
gesetzen nichts also was im ganzen
zweckmäßig ist zu erwarten
also wir haben einen guten grund in uns
die welt als theologisch strukturiert zu
denken aber das ist etwas anderes als
unlogisch zu behaupten wir müssen zu
urteilen eigentlich als als ob die welt
zweckmäßig verfasst wäre eine weitere
theorie ist ein hebel
ja das ist auch noch interessante
position hegel denkt im gegensatz zu
kant das leben nicht mehr bis
theologisch nicht nur
erkenntnistheoretische denkt es aber
auch nicht ontologisch wie sas tod lässt
tut sondern denkt ist logisch ok
was denkt könntest du dir darunter
vorstellen wie kann man leben logisch
denken ja vielleicht wenn man so rein
strukturell betrachtet wie in der
modernen logik daran geht das formale
logik der eine möglichkeit den lebens
begriff zu formalisieren notwendige
hinreichende bedingungen oder so dass
das meint jetzt siegel aber gerade nicht
und er hat eine theorie verfasst die
heißt wissenschaftler logik für ihn geht
es darum dass die ganze welt die ganze
existenz begrifflich strukturiert ist
begrifflich sich entwickelt und zwar
dynamisch wirklich nur gesetzt sondern
aus basalen begriffen entwickeln sich
logisch notwendig komplexere begriff
also alles beginnt mit dem science
reines seil aus dem griff des seins
folgt das nichts und in dem
dialektischen entwicklungsschritt folgt
dann das werden aus seien nicht die
veränderung genau richtig werden und da
haben wir dann schon so eine basis für
das leben weil ja auch begrifflich
logisch immer in bewegung sein dass das
heißt die begriffe für außerdem
begriffen folgt einfach begriffs logisch
genau der begriff das genau an einem
bestimmten entwicklungs gesetz der
dialektik ekeln dass diese elektrischen
dreischritt these antithese synthese
kommen wir irgendwann im komplexeren
sphären zum dürfte das leben ist okay
genau und lesen man zitat fußball wind
gesagt das leben in seine ideen näher
betrachtet ist an und für sich absolute
allgemeinheit die objektivität welches
an ihm hat ist von begriffe schlechthin
durchdrungen
sie hat nur ihm zur substanz das ist
erstmal sehr wenig verständlich aber es
ist jedenfalls eine begriffliche stufe
in der ganze komplex entwicklung und
kirche sowie nur dazu zählt er halt hier
geht genau dann haben wir einen jüngeren
philosophen der war schon ein bisschen
älter jetzt ist helmuth plessner helmuth
plessner denkt das leben jetzt nicht
unlogisch so sehr wie aristoteles auch
nicht biologischen kant auch nicht
logisch vehikeln sondern könnte sagen
phänomenologische also betrachtet das
leben in seiner
helligkeit gefühls aspekt auch immer das
sagen wie fühlt sich das leben an das
wäre jetzt ihre existenz philosophie bei
neukirchen solchen meint auch nicht
lebensphilosophie wie bei schopenhauer
das ist auch noch so ein begriff sind
schaut einfach wie im wie gestaltet sich
das leben also was für typische
charakterzüge hat das leben an sich wenn
wir es betrachters liegt irgendwie
zwischen der des theologischen theorie
und der unter logischen theorie könnte
man sagen
und er hatte auch ganz zentrale begriffe
ein wichtiger begriff für das leben ist
für ihn die grenze oder auch die
plastizität also schaut wiegen grenzt
sich lebendes von anderen leben ab das
ist ein wichtiger punkt ist eine
physiologische herangehensweise und auch
die zeitlichkeit spielt eine ganz
wichtige rolle für ihn fürs leben primär
zeitlich verfasst während mit tasse
zeitlich indifferent ist die zeit weil
sie das selber gar nicht wahrnimmt die
zeit genau sie hat keine wahrnehmung sie
kann das reflektieren also die zeit ist
eine ganz wichtige wichtiger aspekt und
er sagt zum beispiel folgen das jetzt im
leben lebendiges sein steht im modus der
gegenwart weil es einem selber vorweg
nach sein ist seine gegenwart ist jene
aktualität die nicht mehr im
unversöhnlichen gegensatz zur potenzial
i tät gedacht werden muss so ein
potenzial i tät zur voraussetzung hat
erfüllte potentially thein sein dass in
sich vermittelt unter dem bilder des
unendlichen kreislaufs oder der ruhigen
flamme die beständige überführung vom
einen in den anderen modus der zeit und
die einheit der überführung das heißt
gegenwart bedeutet also leben ist nach
lässt sich immer vorweg gerichtet es hat
ein ziel eine theologie schon
aristoteles sagte und es deswegen nicht
indifferenten derzeit sind es ist
gerichtet hat eine diese zeitliche
ausrichtung erst zeitliche struktur
das ist auch ein interessanter ansatz
von helmuth plessner und ein anderer auf
prominente ansatz in der philosophie des
lebens nicht der lebensphilosophie
philosophie des lebens ist als jonas
diesem jahrhundert der hat jetzt nun das
leben kann
zentral auf den freiheitsbegriff gezogen
als er sagt der organismus alles leben
ist ja organisch verfasste organismus
ist eine ganz spezielle form von
freiheit wie kommt er darauf ich kann
auch mal ein zitat vorlesen von ihm
er sagt im begriff der freiheit besitzen
wir einen leitbegriff für die
interpretation des lebens das werde
geheimnis selbst ist unzugänglich so
bleibt es eine vermutung für mich
persönlich eine starke hypothese dass
schon das gründende prinzip des
überganges von leblose zu leben der
substanz eine so zur bezeichnete tendenz
in den tiefen des seins selber war also
begriff der freiheit ist die
interpretation basis für alles
lebendigen hat der organismus bezieht
sich auf sich selbst also der organismus
erhält sich selbst er ist autark
unabhängig von anderen einflüssen
aber freiheit wer jetzt nicht die
ursache für leben weil ich würde wenn
ich jetzt ich kann ja nicht frei
bestimmen das ich geboren werden wer
durch diese erfassen zwang ich komme auf
die welt
richtig aber wenn man mal auf der welt
ist und die struktur eines organismus
hat ja als eines sich selbst
regulierenden systems kann man das schon
eine gewisse analogie zum
freiheitsbegriff sehen und
selbstbestimmung organismus ist
eigentlich selbst bestimmen das system
was die materie ständig auswechselt und
einem gewissen regulation prinzip voll
und das könnte man durchaus mit feiert
in verbindung bringen interessanter
ansatz von hans jonas und ganz zum
schluss gibt es noch neueren er
analytischen löw michael thompson ja der
hat jetzt den begriff der lebensform
geprägt leben als lebensform und in
diesem zusammenhang noch den begriff des
naturhistorischen urteils als er sagt er
fragt auch ähnlich wie kant wie reden
wir über das lebendige aber auch wie
hegel welche logik liegt im leben zu
grunde ja und er bringt das beispiel
die eule jagd in der nacht dass wir so
ein typisches naturhistorisches urteil
die eule hier macht damit ist jetzt
nicht gemeint dass diese eule hier diese
eule hier oder diese rolle hier in der
nacht gehabt bei nacht sondern die eule
als alle daten also der begriff der eule
sagen und ich hätte es auch noch etwas
vor
von ihm zum naturhistorischen urteil
nennen wir die gedanken die in der natur
führen und filmen zum ausdruck gebracht
werden naturhistorische urteile ihr
kanonische ausdruck besteht in sätzen
der form dass es ist oder hat oder tut
es zb die hauskatze hat vier beine zwei
augen zwei ohren und eingeweiht im bauch
oder die texas bluebird beherbergt stift
stickstoff bindende mikroben in
bestimmten knoten an ihren wurzeln der
gelbe fleck fink brütet im frühling
wobei er paarungspartner durch das und
das lied anlockt und was auch immer
sofort letzten endes interessiert uns
natürlich die zugrundeliegenden urteile
und die form der tatsachen diese
erfassen aber solche sätze werde ich
aristotelische kategorische aussage
nennen unsere sprache erlaubt natürlich
den ausdruck derselben urteile auf
verschiedene weisen etwa durch es sind
haben tun f oder es gehört zu einem sf
zu haben
tun oder es ist charakteristisch oder
typisch für ein sf zu sein haben tun und
100 andere also bei michael thompson
sehen wir am schluss so eine mischung
hinsichtlich der bestimmung des lebens
wir haben einerseits ansätze von
aristoteles die begriffe kategorien
andererseits starke elia mission
einfluss eine gewisse logik der begriffe
die unsere urteil zugrunde liegt und in
der art und weise auf das urteilen zu
reflektieren in michael thompson
herangehensweise auch derjenigen von
kant die kritik der theologischen
urteilskraft okay könntest du jetzt zum
ende auch noch kurz erklären was der
unterschied zwischen lebensphilosophie
und ja also wichtige frage weil man sie
häufig oft vermischten der also
lebensphilosophie ist eine strömung die
im ende des 19 jahrhunderts aufkam
zum beispiel schopenhauer schopenhauer
er hat seine vitalis muss das sagt die
welt als wille und vorstellung also die
welt unsere existenz ist vitalis tisch
gedacht sie hat ein willens ist
dynamisch das führte dann auch weiter
dass ihre existenz philosophisch dachte
oder fragte wie können wir unser leben
bewältigen das geht häufig auch um die
existenz philosophie bei sartorius
weiter dass die lebensphilosophie und
die philosophie des lebens die
betrachtet nicht so sehr die menschliche
existenz sondern begriff des lebens
allgemein oder reflektiert dann zum
beispiel auch begriffe wie sie auf
evolution hat auch eine viel größere
nähe zur natur wissenschaften ok danke
ja dann bis nächstes jahr hier